je trouve cet argent pour vous donner la
lumière
alors qu'est-ce que c'est que la faire
bouger les bouder sont des gens de très
braves gens vraiment de très braves gens
que j'aime bien qui m'aime bien je crois
c'est vraiment le très grave genre
une petite maison
la guerre qui n'a que la guerre que
c'est toutes les chevrons
et pas en très bon état si est quand
même admirablement placé qui est à deux
pas de la route à 25 mètres 50 mètres de
la route nationale des lacs
une forêt et avec quand même une
propriété qui lui appartient de 17
hectares passé vers les années 58 58 60
il y a eu dans le cas du visage
agriculture avec l'aide du département
du conseil général de l'époque les
syndicats d'électricité je sais quoi
exactement bon je l'occasion
il y a une politique d'aménagement des
quartiers non équipés en électricité qui
ont été équipés avec les crédits
spéciaux qui n'ont pas coûté d'argent
aux gens qui étaient sans lumière c'est
ce qu'on appelait le programme
d'électrification des écarts ce qui est
certain c'est que pour des raisons qui
sont ce qu'elles sont les boudés n'ont
pas voulu je crois que les potos passent
dans le propriétaire fais j'en sais rien
faire en tout cas ils n'ont pas la
lumière moi j'ai toujours voulu
la lumière elle est toujours voulu mais
c'est le voisin qui n'a pas voulu qu'on
fasse dans sa propriété il a pas voulu
faire tomber les arbres pour la lumière
chez le voisin il voulait passer alors
si l'ancien maire avait dit vous faites
le tout c'était pas pour un poteau de
pluie ça faisait je sais pas moi 8 ou 9
proto c'était tout il avait exigé
c'était j'aurais eu la lumière comme les
autres j'ai demandé à 70 j'ai demandé à
73 j'ai demandé à 75 j'ai demandé tout
le temps on m'a toujours dit oui mais je
ne vois toujours rien venir en 91 je me
suis trouvé au repas des vieillards des
vieux quoi et j'ai demandé à Monsieur le
Maire de me recevoir il m'a dit oui
venez samedi je suis allé le samedi
là-bas et ma foi il y avait j'étais la
deuxième ou la troisième mais moi on m'a
passé la dernière et encore je lui ai
forcer la main il m'a reçu je lui ai dit
je viens pour ma lumière il m'a dit
comment voulez-vous que je trouve cet
argent pour vous donner la lumière mais
moi je n'ai pas d'argent pour participer
à cette à l'électrification car je ne
tourne nous avons à tous les deux
profits 3500 ans par mois alors nous ne
pouvons pas
nous pouvons nous ne pouvons pas fournir
de l'argent à l'électricité de France
pour nous mettre à l'argent et du moment
qu'on a mis pour les autres pour rien
mon mari il a donné même un morceau de
terrain pour que pour faire la route qui
est face à la le 2390 m de terrain sur
15 mètres de large il nous a jamais été
payés qu'on nous a pris mais on nous a
pas demandé combien nous devait alors
j'estime bien qu'ils peuvent quand même
me donner aujourd'hui la lumière
a fait une nouvelle demande
d'alimentation et nous lui avons
transmis un nouveau devis actualisé qui
est aujourd'hui de 155 000 francs la
maison de Monsieur veut madame Boudet
est environ à 900 mètres du réseau
électrique aujourd'hui ce qui veut dire
que pour alimenter ces personnes il nous
faut environ avec une équipe de travail
de deux personnes en gros une semaine et
nous avons à ce moment-là planté une
douzaine de supports donc de poteaux
béton ou bois
plus le câble électrique pour les
alimenter alors effectivement on peut
trouver que le devis est excessif et
très lourd pour une famille qui a
semble-t-il des revenus à ses moyens
c'est dur pour elle maintenant j'ai 74
ans et je ne peux plus mon mariage à 71
ans 72 bientôt et ne peut rien non plus
j'avais ça sans lumière c'est très dur
sans avoir un peu au moins le minimum de
confort
je crois qu'on pourrait faire quelque
chose pour nous parce que après tout
nous avons nous avons toujours voté nous
avons toujours été bon citoyens je crois
de Gujan-Mestras on ne peut pas se
plaindre de nous et je crois qu'on
pourrait nous faire
quelque chose
j'ai entendu parler
concernant manque d'électricité
paraît-il que monsieur n'a pas été dans
les bois depuis Koh-Lanta depuis 55
parce que il a peut-être eu l'occasion à
savoir de profiter des avantages je
dirais même gratuit
bon mais il s'avère comme une tranche de
cette affaire là on a fait une affaire
d'État
parce qu'il y a un monsieur qui n'a pas
voulu qui n'a pas accepté
pour quelle raison libre à lui
l'électricité
ce qui lui arrive mais qu'est-ce que
vous voulez c'est comme ça
le reste est maintenant
[Musique]